Bà mối thằng sau, trần tiên tré phang sửa xãng của một phòng ngày trở biết.
Đần tờ bằng khai, gây niệm xây đất trình khai gần khu vực prox,
biến đọc uống khai nè, nhưng vụ buộc cái nghiệm buộc học cần sửa chữ ở vả chính xác tại tình tuyến.
Video cân bộ chú thấy đoạn tò được chẳng bị pháo phòng khong dù 2,5,5,
súng mấy N.S.V.Yu Chiaus, con nhiều lấp bảo vệ mang kým lỗi dài và khai nằm cho bình sĩ.
Đáng chú ý phía ngay sân nhận, tò nhiên xây con thích hợp một xây chiến đấu bộ bình bây mở bê hai,
có khả năng phóng tây lợi chúng tăng khó nếp đống với trọng hoả lực chính.
Để cạnh đó các uống ở về chính xác được chỉnh 2,
để hỗ trợ phát hiện sớm các mùi đe dọa tự uống khai nè.
Về phía uống khai nè, một số 1 tiên quân sự cho biết,
viết ngà sự dụng tờ bóng khác cho thay sự khai đổi trong chiến thật phòng thủ hậu cần.
Sòng cũng có thể chụi thành một tiêu tấn công ước tiên của các lực lượng kia.
Hẹn chưa có phản nứng chính thức từ phía uống khai nè về đoàn tạo như thế này.
Đi ta sớt các phương tịt mọc khác trong chiến tranh hiện đại.
Cho thay ngà đăng tìm các ký thập giữa cơm hệ và hình thái chiến đấu chuyển thống,
để tích ứng với điện hình và cục dịch dụng đồ.